hello and uh thanks for joining us for
this uh richard m carp distinguished
lecture my name's peter bartlett i'm the
associate director of the uh simons
institute for the theory of computing
um we established the rm carp series to
celebrate the pioneering role of simon's
institute founding director dick carp in
theoretical computer science and we're
grateful to the many contributors to the
richard m carp fund who've made this
series possible
the series features visionary leaders in
the field of theoretical computer
science on topics associated with
current programs at the institute
and it's geared towards a broad
scientific audience
and this semester the institute's
hosting hosting two programs one on
learning and games and one on causality
and i'm delighted to welcome our speaker
today professor eva tarosh who's one of
the organizers of the program on on
learning and games
so ava is the jacob gould sherman
professor of computer science at cornell
university
where she's currently serving a second
term as chair of the department of
computer science she's also served as
interim dean for computing and
information sciences and associate dean
for diversity and inclusion
ava received her degrees from adverse
university in budapest
her research interests are in algorithms
and the interface of algorithms and
incentives and she's perhaps best known
for her work on network flow algorithms
and for quantifying the efficiency of
selfish routing
she's the co-author of the widely used
textbook algorithm design and the
recipient of many fellowships and awards
including the packard fellowship
the girdle prize the dancing prize the
fuckerson prize the eatcs award and the
ieee von neumann medal and she's been
elected to the national academy of
engineering the national academy of
sciences the american philosophical
society the american academy of arts and
sciences and the hungarian academy of
sciences
her talk today is titled stability and
learning in repeated games please join
me in welcoming eva tarosh
thank you so much thank you for the
introduction
uh i guess i have to start with the sort
of awkward question that i'm very unsure
about the masking etiquette here
uh i guess i thought peter i was
thinking of using the cornell rule of
masking where cornell currently says
that the
speaker should not be masked because
that way it's easier to understand and
anyway there is a distance well we
require our students to ask if anyone is
uncomfortable with the fact that i'm not
masked i do have a mask so just let me
know
and i can change my strategy but i
figured speaking with an accent you
probably i'm better off if i'm not
masking
the second point
is that
i understand that this is a very
uh diverse and interesting audience
consisting of people in our program on
learning and games who might have seen a
lot of what i'm talking about and many
of you who are not from those programs
or haven't seen or maybe haven't seen it
even though you were from that program
so what i'm trying to do is both give
you a bit of background of what is it
that um we are trying to what i'm trying
to work on and a little bit of
how do we do what we do uh you can
definitely control
like sort of slow me down or speed me up
by asking the right kind of questions
and i very welcome
audience interactions so please
uh you know ask questions or interrupt
so what i want to talk about is
is uh
interesting questions and learning in in
repeated games and to start with sort of
the really
uh distant interaction interest in this
um you know for the last
at this point
well over 20 or maybe 30 years many of
us have sold about interaction selfish
interactions of multiple agents uh and
asked the questions of what kind of
outcome should we expect and
and this price of energy question that
is how good are these outcomes that that
players achieve as they interact with
each other
what i want to
talk about today
is
is uh
more focusing on
interactions which are repeated like
there's not a one shot you play the game
it's over you got to reward then you're
done but something that that these
participants participate over and over
again and in particular the main message
is this line here very many of those
interactions the natural form that
people do is somehow take
the observation of what happening in the
game as they playing it and using it to
figure out what to do next that is they
use some sort of learning algorithm to
um
learn what to do in this situation uh
there are many great questions one can
ask here uh from
um which i'm going to maybe get to or
maybe just hit that uh what do i mean by
learning so what's the right that what
does it mean that they learned what do
they learn from data from from
data what are uh forms of learning
that guarantees that something decent
happens as an outcome
and
um generally what can we say about
outcomes in learning
to get you started a couple sort of my
favorite applications here
uh i guess the all-time favorite the one
peter mentioned that maybe
i'm most known for is traffic writing
with delays traffic can be car traffic
or
internet traffic
whether it's a car and you're driving
someplace every every morning or whether
it's internet traffic and the rattlers
are actually doing the wrapping for you
this is a repeated game the rather
repeatedly sending packets not one
packet and then they're done similarly
for you and driving if you live far far
away far away from where you work then
every morning you get a new car and
drive there that also is a repeated game
you figure out what is the right way to
get there uh i guess that the particular
results is going to about this uh
queuing system which is meant to be a
very very simplified version but they
may be incorporating more realistic
features than what we had on the package
routing in the work on package wrapping
assume that congestion causes delays
that is there are more cars there it's
slower to get across
um
but
it is
making some assumptions for example in
true packages i think packets get
dropped and have to get resent and
that's not in this model so uh in the um
queuing system application i actually
focus on that part and say what if you
know there's this package they get to
send to the servers if the server can't
serve it the server instantly drops the
packet and you're going to have to
resend it so that's going to be them all
but i come back to this in a second then
i guess maybe the killer application on
which unfortunately i can't present
results yet or it would be nice to have
results uh one that are our
uh
google or internet industry monitors
repeated auction that too is a repeated
game uh advertisers repeatedly bid on
getting shown on the web that is a
repeated game
um
so
you can ask what what is that what
should i expect as an outcome of such a
repeated game
i'm going to focus on the assumption
that the players are learning they're
using some sort of machine learning
algorithm to figure out what to do
that is they they
use data that's available to them to
adopt the learning situation
and i guess here are the questions
that one would naturally ask
it's generally reasonable to ask what
kind of information is available to the
players i'm not going to focus on this i
can tell you that the kind of results
i'm presenting is possible to do
learn learn enough with very minimal
information about what they learn if you
give them more information they might be
able to learn faster
and mostly we'll focus on this question
what learning properties would would
guarantee okay social welfare
so what do i mean what would be so
for those of you who especially from our
program would think that this is also
ancient history and for the last
say 15 years or something close to 10 to
15 years there have been a lot of
results on
what's called no regret learning and
here is what learning grad learning is
trying to do so if i take
the nash equilibrium
one early hope would be that as you
learn everyone converges to a stable
outcome which would be a nash
equilibrium what is a stable outcome
mean they play some sort of strategies i
guess a1 to am is the strategy that
player one through n is playing here at
time one then they time two times three
eventually they settle on something and
then just repeat it and they seem happy
to repeat that thing why would they be
happy to repeat it because if it
satisfies this condition which is the
nash condition and maybe introducing the
notation here so this is cost that
player i played if they've played the
vector of all a's these are the
uninducts a's or super index is
it's lesser cost than anything else this
person can do given that everyone else
is staying with their strategy that's
the nash equilibrium it's
my my strategy ai is best response to
what everyone else is doing which is
this a minus i everyone except for me
that's called the no regret condition
and it's a nash equilibrium
and what the no regret learning
algorithm which sometimes also goes
under the name of one and consistent
would be is to get rid of the oh sorry
get rid of the assumption here that they
found the stable solution but keep this
which in particular means something like
this that they do something who knows it
might not have gotten stable or probably
it didn't get stable but if i take
uh whatever cost they're playing it's
less than any fixed strategy with
hindsight there isn't a strategy x that
they feel bad about or to be very more
precise because there is an upfront part
where they're doing the learning they
might make mistakes up front but the
cost they're playing
over time
is better than had they played this
fixed strategy x over time
okay that's the goal and this is a as it
turns out and i'll say a couple more uh
words about this in a minute this is a
very algorithmically achievable strategy
but it's trying or goals but it's trying
to say
that if this fails that is the opposite
inequality is true
then
there is a strategy x
that is so much better than what you're
doing please wake up to this fact it's
so you know you're driving to work and
for whatever dumb reason you're driving
around the earth in the wrong direction
there is the right direction it's always
very fast why didn't you try it
and the way these algorithms work is
maybe better if i admit to you
so many simple rules assure this but to
actually foreshadow where i'm heading
um
this is really what we're doing and this
is a bit more complex notation that i
want to put in in a second
it actually often interaction the cost
you're paying is not only dependent on
what you did this very second but also
what happened yesterday or the day
before
depends on the history so in a better
notation
this is the cost
over time that you play your i place at
time t
but not only depending on what happened
at time t but also what happened in all
the previous time periods so this one
semicolon t is like the whole history so
this is what he's playing at time t
given the history
and what what these algorithms achieve
is that it's that cost is no verse or
better than what would have happened if
you kept the history but every now and
then tried this x strategy as an
experiment
and this sort of also tells you again a
little bit of error this is just the
error term uh this is you know
foreshadowing you are telling you how
these algorithms achieve it it they
often refer to as explore exploit what
they're doing is every now and then
testing x
and if x is very good when you test it
well then i guess you should do that x
is not very good when you test it then
you should back off so they trying this
sort of you know switch off to x every
now and then and this is the guarantee
they achieve
again they achieve it with this explore
exploit kind of
strategy there are lots and lots of
algorithms going back to even earlier
than the ones so i'm listing here the
two eye lists are both sort of maybe
simpler
and uh maybe my favorite
um and i guess one thing i like pointing
out that this assumption that people
achieve this condition is weaker than
another commonly used condition in the
economy conscious literature that they
reach a nash equilibrium if they were to
reach a nash equilibrium that is if they
reach a stable outcome in which they
happy they obviously satisfy that
condition
so it's a weaker condition it's
algorithmically achievable unlike the
nash equilibrium that has ppad
completeness results that i didn't
missed here but
i guess we or not
um
so what i like to see what i maybe used
to like thinking about and which i'm
going to criticize in about 10 seconds
is i like this no regret condition but
at the same time there are some
handicaps so right i will tell you first
why i like the condition and i tell you
why one doesn't like the condition
because every coin has two sides this
one certainly does so what's good about
the no regret condition
so i don't want to think about i want to
think about it is a behavioral model and
i want to claim that this is not a bad
behavioral model
and i guess one way to try to prove it
to you is to look at data and see do
people actually achieve this model so
there's a huge bunch of papers at this
point
um thinking about whether it's true or
not true
a
large number of them including one that
i'm a co-author of here uh was trying to
say yes yes no regret condition is red
players as they repeatedly play games
they achieve this condition
um two of those are lab experiments
and the one that
uh
that that is joined with
uh dennis who who
i think at the end didn't come but was
supposed to be in this program and
vasily who's the main organizer despite
peter giving me some credit for this
[Music]
we're looking at bing data advertisement
data on microsoft auctions and our basic
all of these papers basic finding is
that reasonably true so are reasonably
true is visiting five to ten percent
it's not the error is not tiny but
you know single digit percentage
um
these guys
uh
nissan and nothing say that you know
if i give a really shitty game to
someone where it's truly frustrating to
play those people don't satisfy the
regret condition is just too frustrating
but most of them do
uh and i guess this is this is really
positive uh there are some papers that
say that it's not getting satisfied
this is one of my favorites in the
negative category
who again is a lab experiment a cellular
buyer game
and the thing they're pointing out that
humans are
recently biased
they not sufficiently react on long
histories if recently something was good
for you they jumped to conclusions too
fast this is a property that i totally
believe humans have and actually for us
it's probably reasonable if you're
driving and you know this month you
discover that certain highway is not is
not jammed
who cares that last year it was jumped
that doesn't matter so recency bias is
something that probably we should be
recently biased but they point is that
if they don't fully satisfy the no
regret condition because they play too
they recently biased and then we have a
paper here again with dennis and a
student of mine uh which where our
conclusion is that people don't satisfy
it and here this is zillow
um
agents advertising on zillow which zero
actually stopped
uh for literally the reason
that
these are real estate agents bidding is
not they think it was too complicated
for them
i think in any event zillow stopped the
bidding system and they're right
it just there wasn't
there wasn't enough attention paid to it
and they really
i don't know what they value for it was
for the ad but there's no value on which
they satisfy the rule so they clearly
were too complex for them
so again on the yeah
would you like to operate a little bit
more about what do you mean that
in the case of uh
i love sargani's work it was it wasn't
true
like
what do you mean
so i get this one yes yes so we're
looking at big data
uh we actually made it
easy on us as in looked at agents that
have very large budgets
this is actually we'll be clear in a
minute of why that was important because
if you have very large budgets
then you're doing a linear optimization
you're supposed to bid
somehow depending on your value for for
showing the ad
maximizing your net utility that is the
value minus the cost you paid for it
that's what you're optimizing which is a
easier objective function than if you
have a budget that limits you so these
are all advertisement is very high
budgets so they're just advertising the
they what they optimizing or they should
be optimizing is the
value they get minus the price
i don't actually know what the value is
but i can tell you that each of them
had a value
under which their behavior was rational
so it's reasonable to believe that
that's probably their value and they did
the right thing
this is as opposed to done here in the
zillow case where
um again we tried to look at bidders
that use large budget so budget wasn't
the limiting sink but there is no value
on which the behavior was rational so
we're international
yeah sure go ahead yes yes great idea um
if you said earlier the no regret is a
weaker notion than nash equilibrium
i'm curious if there's any relationship
between that and self-confirming
equilibrium that fuedenberg in the game
in the early 90s
so i guess the point is that this this
is not an active or it's a correlated
equilibrium but it's not a stable
acquiring concept so what i'm giving up
on is the stability
and if you look at which i guess we i
don't have any stone but the full talk
we gave on used to give only on the
paper miss denison and wesley uh we
usually talking specifically about that
we usually show data for the microsoft
uh big ads
where it's very clear they're not
reaching an equilibrium
that is people
my guess is that they're using a
gradient descent stand learning
algorithm that they pushing they beat up
and then they push it down and cause it
seems to go in waves but they're not
stabilizing
and you can ask why they're not
stabilizing which is an excellent
question but one reason they're not
severalizing because learning algorithms
do not lead to a stable outcome they
exactly lead to this
baby behavior
but yet it satisfies this condition
why could they satisfy this condition
you can say because the condition is
weak a single strategy is hindsight when
when the other guy is going up i should
have been glowing when he's going down i
should have been high
but that's not i'm asking i'm not asking
you for something that complicated i'm
asking you for something simple a single
strategy with hindsight and that's
achievable these algorithms to achieve
it but they don't stabilize
so it's it's it's a different relaxation
than nationally
filler works in does that make sense
so i like it there's a there are many
good algorithms and there is a lot of
work happening in our program of people
trying to find better algorithms or
algorithms for cases where we didn't
have algorithms i really like this as a
as a
behavioral model
that is not assuming that they ran a
particular named algorithm but instead
taking a condition and say there are
many algorithms i don't care which one
they ran as long as they satisfy that
condition that's my behavior model and i
like this line here is that all i'm
asking that is that it's a very simple
thing it's a consistently good strategy
please welcome to this
that's all i'm asking
and then in particular like it because
i'm a theoretician as many of the people
or maybe all of us here to some more or
less extender and it's a condition
that's nice to use in theory so that's
what i like about it
um
there are many positive results which
i'm going to only flash here and not
actually uh elaborate on them so price
of honor he was originally defined by
cotsupius and papanimichio and it meant
it considered nash equilibria and this
was the definition you looked at you the
game the cost or utility achieved
compared to an optimum
cost
and then in a sequence of papers which
again i said it's 15 or plus years ago
maybe more than that by now uh was
extended to this no regret earning
outcomes
with the
obvious definition that is the utility
or cost these people achieve as they
play the game so summed over all the
agents some over all the time
utility of everyone compared to the
optimum if you played for capital t
times then i guess you can just repeat
the same thing and the optimum went up
by a factor of t and i guess the main
message is that all these proofs that we
had
um you know
now 20 somewhat years ago uh on the
price of energy or almost all of them
extend to no regret learning outcomes
and that was really a nice
uh
originally started by a paper actually
the whole using it as a behavior
condition was started by an avrom blah
blah blah and rose paper uh and then
the observation that all our results
extend to this was a paper by rough
garden a year year later and there are
really lots and lots of results like i
feel the slide visit there are many more
um
that's not what i'm going to talk about
because this was the sort of sort of the
background here
um
i i promise that i'm also going to admit
that some things is wrong with no regret
learning and here are a few things that
are wrong one of which i'm going to
focus on
uh for the time i have
uh so limitations
um
there are nice papers including by some
participants around here that it's too
much like it's actually too hard to
learn no regret depends on
what the game is
certainly many settings is too much to
expect
there are also interesting results in
the auction setting that definitely the
standard or that algorithms are super
dumb to play that is you can take
advantage of the players if they do that
and extract all the money from them so
it's a dumb thing to do
i'm going to focus on this one
that
in some settings where it's doable but
it doesn't seem strong enough
and i'm hoping that
there are a better condition that maybe
shares the properties of the
of what we had about no regret learning
and these are the two conditions i would
like to have i want to have a more
general condition that also is usually
true in beta that these people do do
that
and implies better outcomes yes
first of all
too much to expect is a hardness result
yes
just to be sure that i have got the
point of the difference here the higher
inequality they see is the classical no
recruit notion yeah while the lower one
is something that you
propose as a
refinement no actually this is so
uh maybe i'll come back let me come back
to your point in a second about the
differences and i'll page back to this
slide and check if
it's clear enough and try to answer your
question
so one critical assumption in all this
work which i didn't emphasize and i want
to say it before i i respond to your
question is that every time you repeat
the game you're playing a
a whole new copy of the game
um that is
the only thing that carries from one
round to the next is what you learned
from the previous round and not anything
about the game the game is not changing
and one question to ask is this a
reasonable assumption and i propose the
answer is of course not
and i guess to sort of make the extremes
if we talk about the morning rusher then
the assumption is that no matter how bad
traffic is monday morning everyone went
home by tuesday it's a new the roads are
empty in the middle of the night they're
empty enough and you can start again on
tuesday but if you think about second
byte second traffic and either cars or
packets then it's not true if you had
trouble in second number 17 then second
number 18 the very same packets are
still there and struggling so then it's
not true and
this is an assumption that when you pay
a new copy of the game
is a fresh new copy with no carryover
effect whether there is a carryover
effect is the main question i want to
ask
and i'm claiming that this whole price
of energy is not as well understood if
there is a carryover effect in fact it's
very not understood if there is a
carryover effect
now this is the moment i want to go back
to
trying to answer your question
uh that notation up there
is implicitly this is the classical
notion of of no regret is implicitly or
maybe explicitly an annotation is
assuming no carryover effect
it says that the cost you're playing or
cost you you pay
at iteration t
has no direct effect of what happened in
iteration once through t minus one the
cost is simply depends on what you did
at iteration t and the previous thing
you know except for your choice of
strategy it has no effect
in this notation that i done here have
done here i
actually admitted that late weight it
could have an effect your cost at
iteration t can implicitly depend on
or not explicitly depend on what
happened in previous iteration because
there are packets left or something and
in that notation what i gave you
is what these algorithms actually
achieve
if there is a carryover effect i can
still run a classical no regret
algorithm it's an algorithm i can follow
the algorithm
but what they achieve is not that
condition which no longer has a meaning
because there is the carryover effect
but this is the condition it achieves
but you can maybe believe me that that's
what it will achieve because these are
all explore exploit algorithms they try
things and they stick with the things
that's good and what this notation says
that the cost of x
had you consistently always tried it but
somehow went with the previous history
this is the explore part
you didn't stick play x all the time
but you just tested it
and was it good when you tested it yeah
so i think there are two questions the
first one is i want to understand from
theoretical perspectives i'm trying to
make a motivation
the third one is if
the actions that i play
where in the marketing or i think later
if all of us we
define i was thinking initially the
model where i'm playing with convex
online convex organization
that is changing in every round but
there is somehow a budget about how much
one game differs from the other because
in the example
of the parking for example it's not that
the next game that i will see is very
very different from the third one so the
first question is how much the
the games differ because and now is the
second
thread of question that if they differ a
lot then we do not speak about the
stochastic game about the mark of
an mdb game where we play and our
actions define somehow
uh
yeah so random these are all great
questions in a much more general setting
our results are in a very concrete
setting with packets where i can tell
you in a minute what the game is and how
how little the change is
but i would love to
generalize it in the direction you're
going with sort of more abstractly
defining and indeed
anything can only or i'm thinking
anything we do can only extend if the
change between iterations is
sufficiently small
again results are but one concrete
setting but
i'm hoping that with a limit like
something along the lines that you
suggest is just limiting the change
between iterations something this might
work
maybe a basic question right what is the
quantification on the other player's
actions is it for all a minus i t that's
true or there exists one or it depends
on so at the moment i'm just telling you
what is it that the classical nordic
algorithm is achieved
you know
your favorite ignorant already multiple
got you made follow the leader your
choice
this is what they achieve they're
against the worst case adversary
the results will showcase a minus i t is
because the algorithms are strong they
go against the
worst case adversary when i switch which
i'll do in a minute of what i can say
about the games i'm going to make the
much better assumption that everyone is
doing this learning center
but they're not first the authors there
is not worst case they too are
doing norwegian learning
right but nerve rate learning is strong
at least these algorithms are they can
achieve they can achieve this condition
against worst case adversaries i can
also comment on that i think that
um again looking at the data
also just show up a second ago but i see
him anymore
oh there he is uh vasily might know more
about the data than i do but our tech
was that what they're doing is gradient
descent and not the inordinate
algorithms
and they achieve the no regret condition
because the data is not worst case
okay
so here is what i again
um
going back to where i was
yeah one quick question just because you
you said that yeah
you don't mean something like
the online grading descent method they
have it in my mind that's a
an ftrl method with a l2 regularizer but
you don't mean that with gradient design
because every time you say they do not
apply and no regret and they apply
credentials
deterministic algorithms won't guarantee
but if the if the environment
sufficiently went down then they work
okay i think that's what's happening
okay so
uh again i claim that this carryover
effect life is much less understood
um and i guess what i'm going to ask is
a question i generally like is in the
skewing system
uh
i can tell you how much capacity is made
to centrally schedule everyone every
packet to get to their destination i'm
asking if i give you enough extra
capacity would learning do it is it good
enough
and
the main point which i'm hoping to still
get to uh is which i maybe will skip
some of the proof slides to make sure i
get there is is no regret the right
notion of learning and in fact i've been
trying to drive you towards that there
are some issues here which maybe you can
guess at this point but i definitely
want to show you the example so this
yeah
could you just say something about what
extra capacity means this may be
something yes one time you know no one
knows it at one tiny second here is them
all so here is the actual simple what
the results are about there are these
queues they're going to get packets
packets will arrive at um you know
bernoulli every iteration every period
with some probability london i get the
new package shows up here these queues
will decide which server they want to
try to send the packets to the servers
can have service rates that is some
probability they succeed at serving your
package
um
you send a bunch of packets then you
know there's some collision here i'm
going to assume that one of them gets
through and the other one gets sent back
and sometimes servers can fail also
servers
the queues can only send one package at
one place at the time and the packets
the servers can only serve one packet at
a time these are the critical
assumptions so as a learner and these
guys are the learners here there are two
things you have to learn which which are
the good good servers and which are the
bad servers but also there are other
people sending their packets so you
don't have collisions so there's a game
here the second part is the game
that is so you learn more than just the
probability of success exactly you're
learning
where are you succeeding
the amount of feedback i'm currently
assuming is just whether you succeeded
or not if your packet came back you
didn't succeed otherwise you did i don't
need you to know whether you succeeded
because it was a bad server or you
failed because someone else got you
it doesn't matter to me but maybe it
would help if i give them more
information yeah so the twos have
different players here
yeah so these guys are different players
that are each trying to learn where to
send their packets be sure
symbolically the server will send back
to the
initial queue
yes
yes
so if you want to be a bit more
realistic for package writing what
really might happen that the packet gets
dropped and you get the message that
your packet got dropped and then you
have to resend it which is
mathematically the same as sending the
packet back
where i'm cheating is that in reality
the servers usually have a tiny buffer
and i'm not mowing the buffer so what
really happens is that up to two or
three it buffers it and then drops and
i'm just assuming you drop it right away
it is something different from
unservant sending back and failing
this is a collision
and avoiding the collision the right way
to get served if i were coordinating it
is you know sending one pocket at the
time everywhere that would be the
coordinated action
and the players are only the future for
the servers
no at the moment only only the servers
earning the queue
i'm making one very critical assumption
down here you have to wonder if there's
a collision in which one of them am i
serving i'm going to make assume that
assume that
the packets are time stamped and the
oldest one gets served this is really
helpful and i guess i can try to
convince you that without this nothing
good will happen
but
if if the servers try to serve you all
this package then there is a hope
that things can get through
so that's them all good moment to ask
questions
uh
and i can tell you in a minute
so this last assumption
um
if i understand it correctly it means
that
uh
you know it's a probability zero event
that two players would send packets at
the exact same moment no no
this the the time time is slotted
um period one period two uh if i want a
continuous time well i have to declare
conflict to be
you know if you're too close to each
other that's a conflict which we didn't
work at so you just sometimes
slaughtered
excellent questions
iteration t they all decide to do
something another concept
excellent question for us so they are
synchronous in the way that they send
but we have to keep them
one random tie breaker
priority in the stamps
for the timestamps
yeah for example i don't care what
happened if the stems are identical
what will matter is what happens with
the stems are sufficiently far apart
um
to give you any results i have to start
by giving you a sort of baseline measure
that if i were to coordinate
what would be reasonable and this one i
hope you're just going to believe me
that that's the condition so for a
baseline measure i can assume that
everything is sorted so just so it's
easy to refer to them so
the cues are and the order on which
highest arrival lost the rival and the
same on the servers
and i claim this is the condition that
is for
the top
uh the best server
should have enough capacity to serve the
highest arrival queue
you know everyone can only send to one
place at a time
so if you know his packet's arriving
faster than even the best server life is
hopeless even if he was alone
similarly if i take the top two servers
dr2qs they together can can try two
servers
there should be enough capacity there or
s life is hopeless and so on all the way
down so for every k if i take the top
key the highest arriving top kick but
packets and making
the best serving top k servers and then
there should be more capacity here than
that
does this require the oldest piece of
this no this doesn't require anything
this is coordinated if i coordinate then
nothing is needed
so this is the condition it's not very
hard to prove and at least hopefully i
convince you that it's necessary even if
i didn't convince you that it's
sufficient but if you coordinate you can
do this yeah
this picture was leading me to think
that there was some kind of graph
structure but you're saying any queue
consented yeah and if you can send to
any server it would be nice to add a
graph structure
so here are the two theorems that i will
not actually prove given that you guys
were really really nice and asked lots
of cool questions
but instead just tell you about
so if everyone every uh every queue is
an regret learner that is satisfies no
regret condition
and i have twice as much capacity as
needed so instead of having this
condition which was the necessary
condition i have it with a factor of two
extra
then no regret learning is good enough
on the other hand if cues are actually
better and this i definitely will show
you not necessarily the proof but the
reason for this
that the
they that
no regret turns out to be too myopic and
if the servers are more patient in how
they learn
then i don't need the factor of two i
need a little bit less it's not a giant
factor up but it shows that something is
like that no regret was not the wrong
condition
now given that i have
uh only a few minutes
uh what i'm going to do is maybe tell
you something about
um
just that one
sentence of what this proof was like i
don't know if that would make you
believe the proof or not
but maybe since i have the slides i will
at least have to flip through them
anyhow
but most importantly i want to show you
the example that shows the difference
between the two because i think that's
the most interesting part here
so what's the the proof for the first
one was a potential function proof
and what i want to argue is that there
is a potential function which is this
time steps of all the packets which
satisfies a very nice random process
theorem by payment pimentel and
rosenthal uh one you're supposed to
prove that is so this is all the time
stamps of all the packets i have which
is what this potential functions sum up
all the time stamps so i have a packet
which is seven step sold and one is 20
steps so if i just add them all up
that's my potential function
and but uh
we need to prove that if this potential
function has a what's called negative
drift so when it's high enough
it's expected to go down
uh that's good enough to prove that the
potential function will stay low the
whole time
or in export his high probability stable
stay stay low and expectations stay low
the whole time uh and that's basically
the proof so i have to argue that when
um there's a lot of odd packets in the
system or at least one packet that's
super old or some combination of those
then
that potential function is expected to
go down
and that's the proof
and i guess due to lack of time i'm
going to still cheat here and not
actually
show you either the proof or the extra
technical details
but instead
show you the example of what's the
difference between these two guys and
maybe depending on
our patients and questions maybe give
you something about the proof of the
lower one so here is my favorite example
from this talk that shows you what's
wrong with no regret learning so here is
a simple example of my setup so there
are two
cues here this is arrival late a little
bit above half and this is also an
arrival rate a little bit above half so
roughly speaking both of those skills
get a new packet every
you know second time bit more than that
and we have two servers a literally
perfect guy that serves someone all the
time and
kind of not so good one less than 50
percent of the time
and i claim that
the unique no regret strategy is to send
all your packets to the top
it's the only thing you can do if you
insist on no regret
right because
these are identical cues and they're
going to you know
uh
split the traffic
identically like 50 50 so they get
served at a 50 rate which by the way is
not enough because they get packets a
bit more than 50 so they're gonna build
up an infinite queue behind them
that's unfortunate but 50 is better than
47 so they have no regret
no
if you start summing anything down there
you have regret
why did i regret because whenever you're
standing here
you only get served 50 47 of the time
this is a pretty shitty server here over
there you got 50 that was better you
should go over there it's not socially
efficient but it's not socially
efficient but the only thing to do in
order to get is to send every one of
your packets out there
again every time you send down here
you guarantee yourself no worth no
better than 47
for sure and up there you were getting
50 50 is more than 47 why would you do
this
but the answer is because you should
it's not only socially efficient it's
actually selfishly good
so what happens if someone actually does
do what i suggested which by the way
these are the right numbers this is the
national this is the
uh
uh nash equilibrium strategy
but what's on the board that is ten
percent down here mine is percent here
and the other guy standing there that's
nash
uh it helps
it looks like this is actually a
a way to help your body
because you know 10 of the time you're
done here
and he's alone so he gets service
but what really happens
is
his packets are less old than yours
because he has this 10 percent advantage
so whenever you go up you're very likely
to have an advantage
so you when you go up you get way more
than 50
remember the time stamps
you're older you probably get served
here
so according to our north graduate you
have an even bigger regret now you don't
have 50 chance of getting suffering like
60 or 65 chance of getting served
but that's happening because it came
down sometimes
if you don't do this then it's 50 50.
so if i go back to what you said then
you get 50 50. if you do this
then you get
even better up there and actually both
of you get across
and there is enough capacity here to get
everyone served yeah
so just to be sure what are the numbers
here
10
so you say
let's say that the ten percent i will
send them to the city one and
the
and would have obviously will get it
back well you know right 50 56
probability
zero point zero four seven probability
so this is forty seven percent success
rate so 53 percent
right right additionally
and that means that i will keep i want
to be sure about the model i will keep
it and in the next round i will sell it
again with probability ten percent down
and nine percent up
and then you say that the
because it has timestamp from the
previous round they are older so when
you go up you will have priority
i see
so what's happening here
is that if you imagine a situation where
lots of packets build up remember i
wrote proof that i cared about when the
timestamps some of that something's very
big so there are lots of packets in the
system then i'm fully utilizing this
server which we know it doesn't have
enough capacity it's only one as opposed
to 1.2
but i little bit use this that adds
enough capacity that i actually get
through
whereas without this link here
you not have enough capacity that just
like there's not enough capacity up
there
so what's really happening from a
learning perspective point of view at
least i think
is that regret is the wrong notion this
instantaneous explore exploit
in a place where there's carryover
effect you should stick to what you want
to do and try it for longer to see if it
has a long-term effect so that's maybe
what i'm going to end the time
yes timestamp plays an important role so
a quick question for you
do people do mixed strategies here or
your love yeah
so this is sort of the learning
difference i want to emphasize
this is what nordic learning algorithms
actually achieve in a carryover thing
this is something i tried to say in the
beginning that is or
is because things depend on the history
this is the
you know instantaneous success when
you're exposing and you you measure the
instantaneous effects of exploring
things what you should be doing is more
like this what's the long-term effect of
trying this accent
and maybe this is too extreme like you
can't you know try everything but
instead of trying it once you should try
it and stick to it for a while and see
if it having a having an effect as you
stick to it that's what we probably
should need
and in a place this carryover effect i
even believe that something like this
this is again too strong but something
like this might actually be true that
people are doing it they're trying
things not instantaneously
i don't know for sure
and i guess where that
point six
three result come from is assuming
something
more
uh in the queuing game i'm going to
actually
uh maybe end with
just showing you the worst case example
where the number of
6.63 came from this is the worst case
equilibrium in the other in this in this
more patient game
uh turn out if
you maybe again you told believe me if
every single server has equal rate and
they uniformly randomize me
which is always the stupid activity like
they you know like boston beans they
uniformly choose one of them at random
that's where the
0.63 is actually
e minus 1 over e that's where the number
came from and what's happening here is
that because they that's such a
symmetric strategy that that's of course
nash
uh and unfortunately one of very
probably one of the servers was unused
which is the wasted space
um so i guess i
love that you guys asked so many
questions but as a result you don't get
to see so much hint of the proof
uh but instead
i will just end this
sorry
uh
a couple conclusions the one i more
talked about and that i sort of want to
think more about my research direction
so i guess in the first statement was
that even if they do learning even in
carryover effects sometimes even regret
learning is good enough
uh but normally learning is seems too
simplistic and i guess i would love to
understand better
what form of this sort of more patient
learning camp will get maybe stronger
his answer is
uh there are many other beautiful
questions and learning in games that i
always wanted to explore and i don't
have very good
um
theoretical results supporting it but
learning seems like an excellent way to
adapt to a possibly badly playing
opponent
unlike nash
like you know i should do better if the
opponent's not playing well uh it
doesn't need to come on prior so they
don't have to know who their
opponents are they can just learn um
[Music]
and i guess
if this is the sort of recency bias it
can possibly adopt through changing
environments if they don't change
customers
i'm going to stop here and thank you
very much
all right good time for
one or two quick questions
thank you thanks for the great talk
um i'm curious if there is a
characterization of
the stationary outcome in the long run
for example the stationary distribution
of acute lens or
expected waiting time or throughput of
the system
those are all great questions and no i
don't have results
actually this whole queuing will
uh june system i learned or thought
originally about a paper in
nips 16 when it was still called
livestream on eurips uh
where
the paper was talking about someone
doing
a single queue doing no regret learning
just trying to learn which are the good
servers
so it's uh exactly the small except
they're not multiple competing servers
but just about one queue and the whole
thing they have to learn is which are
the good servers and they have very
precise results exactly of the kind
that you're suggesting for single
the server has what the queue has to
learn is which is the good server
and not very surprisingly the same
condition like you in order to get
across they need one of the servers to
be good enough
so what should happen is that the queue
length behind you grows up because you
initially don't know and you keep
getting your packets rejected and
eventually you figure out which one is
the better server and then your q length
goes down and they have very nice exact
characterization goes up to lock
something and then like that
so they have exactly what you want
except there's no competing players i
wish i could do this for competing
players also
maybe one more
thank you thank you everyone
so uh i was wondering about the
second bullet there the second blue
bullet uh blue bullet
the second one
yeah uh so
the types of environments you think
about are
can be modeled in the language of
multi-agents and important learning
right the state and people like and so
forth and you're interested in sort of
like some policy uh regret yeah
uh so
uh you know one one new point to look at
uh this bullet is to say okay like
develop methods for some you know
for general multi-agent rl but is there
some uh kind of like special
[Music]
case of this problem or
uh uh not so sure
so one ben so i guess one proposal here
which at least if you you know uh a
reasonable guess and certainly was my
first guess that oh we have an algorithm
we have policy regret if i make them
play
no policy regret instead of no regret
that will be good enough so what's
policy regret
as an argument does exactly what i hoped
it would do that is instead of trying
the new
alternate policy x one time and then
jumping away
it tries it for one period if that
didn't work maybe try things for two
periods then for four periods and like
longer and longer periods and then it
achieves a guarantee sort of like what
we want
uh as it turns out
by a follow-up paper uh
points out that policy regret as a
behavioral property is not strong enough
that is the same factor of two band
is still
in a really convoluted awkward
choreographed dance between the players
they can
fail to get their packets through even
though they have policy no policy with
that
i'm very suspicious that if they
actually run the no police surrogate
algorithm they would do okay
this is a stupid like
there are a bunch of results out there
in the classical old word without the
carryover effect when you say that no
regret is not strong enough and usually
what those say is that you do a
awkward choreographed dance
uh which does satisfy the nougat
property but it's a really unnatural
thing to do and that fails to achieve
the property and there's a copy of that
result in in our case
that is a exact same lower band the
factor of two lower band
where the players have
they they uh
have the
policy regret property but they do
something super crazy and choreographed
like every
you know as a
prescribed sequence
it does have the property of of having
the price regret but it's not something
you would reach in a natural algorithm
so to be clear your requirement is not
no policy regret like the requirement
that you would like i mean but the
results we have is only about
uh stationary equilibrium that is if if
they reach a nash equilibrium i can
pitch back to the point 63 this point 63
is only an equilibrium equilibrium
i would like to get that we are learning
at some point i hope that i know the
condition it should be policy regret and
i know that's not true okay so i either
need a different condition
or possibly
something about how this policy regret
algorithm work the counter example is a
really really unnatural sequence of
steps which does have the policy regret
but it's not working okay very
interesting
thank you i mean
you know some
but these algorithms which are more
natural no regret conditions than than
sort of the worst case no regret
conditions are really crazy
right we might take the other questions
offline please join me in thanking ava
for a fascinating talk
thank you for asking so many questions
that was really